My name is Shamim Nemati.
I'm an assistant professor of
biomedical informatics here at the Emory School of Medicine.
Prior to coming to Emory,
I was a Ph.D. student at MIT where I worked on
developing algorithms for early prediction of success using the MIMIC database,
which is the world's largest critical care public data set available.
This data set was developed over a period of 10 years using
the data from the Beth Israel Deaconess Hospital Critical Care Center.
And my intention was to build predictive analytic algorithms that can catch
sepsis ahead of time.
So sepsis is related to
blood infection and is the number one killer of people in the ICU.
Every year around 750,000 people they
die in the intensive care unit due to consequences of sepsis,
with the annual cost of over 20 billion dollars.
If you want to break it down it turns out regular individuals who go to
ICU they may stay there for 45 hours or so,
versus for septic patients they may stay in the ICU for over 110 hours.
So this added length of a stay in the ICU is one of
the causes for increase in costs associated with sepsis.
I developed these algorithms at MIT using the MIMIC database and when I came to Emory,
I wanted to validate these algorithms using the Emory data.
So I went to the clinical data warehouse here at Emory,
that is a database that is built on
Emory patients and I asked the question, "do you have the data?"
And they said, "yes."
So I got the data and I right away noticed that the data format is very
different from the data that I had previously from the MIMIC database.
So I spent the next nine months cleaning up the data
and put it in the right format for my algorithms to use.
Right away I realized that,
that would not be practical in general.
Then I decided to build a similar algorithms for real time data and I
realized that I had to do the same thing with the epic and [inaudible] electronic medical records.
That's when I started talking to
the Georgia Tech team and I described my problem to them and we
together we decided to build
a FHIR based sepsis prediction algorithm and that was the beginning of our collaboration.
Yes.
So the app is called sepsis watch and it was built in
association with the Georgia Tech CS44O students during their spring semester of 2017.
Let me actually show it to you.
So the idea of this app is to build
a predictive analytic algorithm for early prediction of sepsis.
However the problem that we have,
is that for data elements to end up in
their patients electronic medical record for us to use it,
a clinician should order these labs to begin with.
Let's focus on an example lets say lactate.
It turns out lactate is important for prediction of sepsis.
But if a clinician doesn't order
the lactate test then you don't have the lab test to make the prediction.
So the first part of this application was to create
visualization for clinicians for most important lab values,
as well as one a step ahead prediction for the labs.
If the lab value in the future is larger,
higher than a critical value,
then the clinician may decide to order a new lab test or decide to
use the lab test value in the context of a predictive analytic algorithm.
If you know that the patient is at risk for sepsis,
using these lab values we can project ahead and we can make a prediction of our sepsis.
Sure.
So here is where FHIR actually is very, very important.
So the first step was to reformat data to make it in a FHIR compatible format.
This allows us to use the same algorithms that we developed for the
Emory data and the sepsis data to apply it to the data that we get here.
With the help of FHIR,
we map the data elements to a set of meta data that are also
known as the fire resources.These fire resources they become the input,
our predictive analytic algorithm for prediction of sepsis.
Once this step is taken care of as a next step we use the FHIR,
a sort of FHIR platform to create visualizations for the clinicians.
So in this case the visualizations involved explain
the current and future values of the labs as well as
risk values for prediction of our prediction of sepsis.
One of the nice thing about working with the students was that some of them they were
very good on the back end and front
end developments with the servers and the smart on FHIR.
Some of them were experienced in machine learning.
So they tried a number of different algorithms and we
settled on a cox proportional hazard model that
aims to look at the patient data at the current time and make
predictions for sepsis up to six hours ahead of time.
With the use of this method we were able to achieve
a very high level of sensitivity and specificity.
As I recall the AUC of the model was around .85 at the level of 85 percent sensitivity.
Which means if you want to catch 85 percent of septic patients
their specificity was around 0.75,
which means around like 25 percent false alarm.
This is really remarkable.
That's why we're very excited about taking it to
the next step and having a clinical implementation of this algorithm.
Here at Emory we
have the privilege of working with very sharp and motivated clinicians.
Our director of critical care Dr. Buchman is
a huge supporter of this type of applications.
I'm currently working with him and
his team to come up with a clinical implementation of this.
So as a first step what we are planning to do is to hire some of
the Georgia Tech students to implement their app on our electronic medical record.
Once the app is in place within the context of our electronic medical record,
then we would need to run the application in the so called silent mode.
What it means is that you run the algorithm in
the background without actually influencing clinical decision making.
So since here you're dealing with prediction task,
the algorithm runs in the background and
gathers the statistics and the statistics tells us how
often the algorithm is able to detect sepsis before the clinicians.
Once that part is done and we can show that in
a real time setting the algorithm can detect sepsis before clinicians,
then we will be in the right setting for proposing
a clinical trial to show it in a more randomized setting.
So that's the next step of our work.
But the FHIR goes beyond this type of validation works.
We have a number of active collaborations with other teams across the country.
They have their own algorithms.
They want to verify and validate their algorithms on our data and vice versa.
FHIR gives us a common language for data exchange and collaboration.
And I think this is the way of.